what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
before we jump into this a fun little
tidbit myself a comic story and run a
channel called eligible monster where we
play video games alongside comic store
games wife Natalie or ads article candy
you could find her on Twitter and we
play video games that have fun so it's
actually pretty cool you guys should
check it out the link will be down in
the description at the top of the
description won't it Gordon Gordon's my
editor so um so here's the cool thing
something that I want you guys that
hopefully you guys have noticed because
you guys will have noticed we've been
running through the Ironman stories we
finished out Captain America that went
into all-new all-different marvel we
finished out for that went into all-new
all-different marvel what I hope you
guys notice or a trend because what
we're doing is I'm literally creating
this massive playlist called the Marvel
major events playlist and it covers all
the major events of Marvel's done for
like the last 10 years which all go in
chronological order as best as I can
make it and then they all go into
all-new all-different marvel so it'll be
like this huge playlist full of stuff
but uh nonetheless so old man Logan
becoming venom this is kind of
interesting because you remember the
original old man Logan's story was
basically an alternate reality story a
dealt with this reality where the
various villains of the marvel universe
had been rallied under the mantle of Red
Skull of course I've covered this story
and I'll pin that an actual story arc
down in the in the comments section so
you guys to see it but it done with the
idea that the Red Skull had rallied all
these villains together and then started
pairing them off with superheroes they
would normally never fight just because
they were better suited fighting some
superheroes than others and so of course
old man Logan when it came to the
Wolverine character largely dealt with
the idea that the villain Mysterio who
had the power to basically create
illusions tricked Wolverine into
thinking that some of their most notable
enemies had invaded the x-men mansion
the result was that he had responded by
killing all the villains only to find
out that the villains he killed were
actually all the other x-men and so the
results of this is that Wolverine
basically destroyed the x-men for the
Red Skull and all the the rogues that
had teamed up with each other and so
because of this it ultimately led to the
whole old man Logan story and the
attempt to take down Red Skull and and
all that kind of good stuff and we'll
get into like the Hulk aspect as we go
through this but the idea is that that
story was an alternate reality story
this is an alternate reality take on an
alternate reality story so it's like two
times removed from the main Marvel
Universe but it's still pretty cool for
what it is because what this does is it
basically follows the aware
oh man Logan story and that's the way it
goes when it comes to alternate
realities if you're new to Marvel Comics
like the what-if series for example
let's say that in the main Marvel
Universe a spider-man was venom which he
was you know Peter Parker became I guess
had the Venom symbiote for a little
while it was the black and white costume
Marvel wanted to shift him up what
Marvel will do is they'll come along and
they'll do a what-if story and they'll
say okay what if spider-man had kept the
Venom symbiote instead of getting rid of
it now what this does is it basically
says okay what if old man Logan had
become venom in the old man Logan
storyline after it finished and that's
kind of the cool thing because what this
does is it picks up after the events are
all said and done now with regard to the
Incredible Hulk and the son of the
Incredible Hulk keep in mind when the
villains had basically conquered the
United States and presumably conquered
the world this ultimately led to the
United States being divvied up in two
different territories of course we never
really found out what happened to the
rest of the world we don't know if the
world was perfectly fine and the United
States was the only country that was
conquered all we're told is that the
United States had been split up into
territories by whoever was strong enough
to rule them and if somebody else came
along and conquered someone and then
took their territory that's just the way
it was for example I believe magneto had
a giant slice in the center of the
country and then kingpin killed him and
took it so it's one of those cool things
when it comes to those those you know
dystopian future stories but with
regards to the Incredible Hulk he ruled
everything from really Washington State
all the way down to New Mexico
California Arizona all that kind of good
stuff and the idea was that he had
effectively taken she-hulk
and then forced her to start procreating
with him take that for what it's worth
this resulted in a whole bunch of you
know really messed up kids really
screwed up offspring but ultimately they
ruled the territory that Wolverine had
set up a family in and so what ended up
happening is that when Wolverine went on
this mission with Hawkeye to basically
try to overthrow the Red Skull and all
went sour the Red Skull ended up getting
killed by Wolverine anyway when he came
back Bruce banners family it basically
killed old man Logan's family and so the
result was that oh man Logan traveled
back to the Bruce Banner family killed
them all and then took banner jr.
basically this little baby that had just
been born and then rode off into the
sunset now different answers have been
given in terms of what happened after
that
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four deals
with the future of that we also have the
old man Logan's story that was written
as part of all-new all-different
by Jeff Lemire one of the greatest
stories and if you're reading it right
now somehow or another the Hulk family
returned and they're led by maestro Hulk
which is like this super powerful
version of the Incredible Hulk and old
man Logan is fighting them and it is
amazing it is so good but what this does
is it basically picks up 15 years after
the events of the original old man Logan
story and what it basically says here is
that old man Logan had basically
revealed to Bruce Banner Jr what he had
done and essentially saying I killed
your father I killed your father and I
killed everybody in your family now he
doesn't explicitly tell him why he tries
to but in the end he doesn't explicitly
tell him why and the reason is because
banner jr. just kind of loses it and
that makes perfect sense if you suddenly
found out you were adopted that's not a
great big huge deal if you found out
that you were adopted and you were
adopted because the person who adopted
you wiped out the entirety of your
family you'd be pretty pissed
you'd be pretty mad and of course you
would seek revenge and so in this
interim where Bruce Banner jr. just kind
of walks away and leaves old man Logan
alone we pick up some time later you
know out in this place in Baja you know
and old man Logan just kind of hanging
out there just being drunk all the time
remember when it came to him as a
character the older he got the weaker
his healing factor got just by virtue of
him being laced with adamantium that was
one of the cool things from the Logan
movie is it actually adapted that
concept from the comics into the film
itself because it's well established in
Marvel Comics the older Logan gets the
weaker is that his healing factor will
get because it's constantly battling
against adamantium poisoning but the
idea is that he suddenly met by the
arrival of Angel now this is kind of a
big deal because angel in the original
old man Logan story I don't remember a
few was just one of the bodies that was
there
honestly I'd have to assume that he
wasn't I mean if he's here in this story
but we never really had any indication
that any of the x-men survived the
slaughter of the Xavier Institute at the
hands of old man Logan now it does make
sense that some x-men wouldn't be there
and remember when the original old man
Logan's story kicked off we never really
saw the battle we've had little bits and
pieces that have been touched on by you
know Jeff Lemire and all-new
all-different marvel with like magneto
levitating into New York and just
bringing the shield Helicarrier crashing
down on the city there's one of the
coolest moments from the whole story we
have little tidbits here and there but
we didn't really get like the full-scale
event so it's entirely possible somebody
survived that's just part of the the
open slate thing that you get when it
comes to these massive stories that skip
over huge chunks of time but the idea
here is that Warren's initial news is
that a new generation of mutants is
basically being trained back at what
used to be the Xavier Institute now
remember this actually falls directly in
line with Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four if you guys never saw my videos on
that in Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four it dealt with the arrival of just
like a new earth out of nowhere and what
we ended up finding out was that in the
far future of the old man Logan universe
this Banner junior kid had basically
risen to become one of a new generation
of superheroes some were mutants who
were basically being reborn others were
you know different characters that had
kind of existed out there but the idea
was that you know the earth was
basically coming to an end Galactus just
wanting to consume it and they all
killed Galactus and then used his body
as a vessel to travel back in time so
again it was kind of a cool scenario
with those things playing out but it
also falls directly in line with the
whole House of M decide check here for a
second and this is something that I hope
you guys have thought about if you ever
read the old man Logan's story and the
old man Logan story what we found out
was that after the death of the x-men no
more mutants were being born mutants
simply ceased to exist we ended up
finding out in this far flung future of
you know the old man Logan universe
mutants were coming back but there was
this time period you know some maybe
hundred years or 150 years or something
like that when mutants simply just
didn't exist anymore now the funny thing
about this and the more I thought about
it the more it seemed to ring true and
the original house of an event The
Scarlet Witch went crazy worked reality
yadda-yadda-yadda
at the end of the story she said no more
mutants so things reset back to normal
the mutant population was reduced to 198
and no more mutants were being born
there was a story where beasts had
analyzed everything that had happened
and had come to the realization that the
scarlet witch's actions had affected the
multiverse which who would have to
include the old man Logan universe so
that would explain how mutants weren't
coming back well then you suddenly have
the events of Avengers vs. x-men where
the arrival of the Phoenix force and the
dispersing of the Phoenix force and hope
becoming the Phoenix force Dalek on his
left leads to the re-emergence of
mutants across the universe and the
multiverse which would explain how it is
that those mutants are coming back in
the old man Logan future not saying is
an absolute truth just kind of a cool
little thing to think about but of
course all of this is basically just
revealed to be a ruse by Warren
Worthington himself by angel in the
sense that he led old man Logan here for
the purpose of taking him out now this
brings in a handful of people it brings
in hawkeye's daughter the new Spider
Woman and then it brings an Bruce Banner
son banner jr. now of course these
characters have all felt disenfranchised
in different ways for example Spider
Girl basically had her Kingdom taken
from her when it was learned that the
reason why she was being held captive is
because in the old man Logan story she
had tried to take out the existing
kingpin the result was that when she was
free by hawkeye and old man Logan she
basically led this ruse that she was
just an innocent victim when she had the
opportunity not only does she take out
the existing kingpin she tried to kill
old man Logan and Hawkeye of course they
defeated all of her forces but in doing
so basically destroyed her Empire they
pulled it out from under her allowing
somebody else to take her place of
course banner jr. basically just has
this grudge against his against old man
Logan and that's really about it now
there are a couple of things here with
regards to how these characters relate
to old man Logan innocence it is really
just them being angry I mean that's
really all it is it's just young angst
then having grudges against old man
Logan a combination of different things
but all come together to sort of create
this perfect storm but what do we get
what we also end up finding out is that
in their efforts to basically get their
revenge on Logan
they had ran out and they had grabbed
the venom t-rex we never found out where
this t-rex came from now it would stand
to reason that if the old man Logan
universe was the same as the main Marvel
Universe it would have to have the
Savage Land the Savage Land is a place
in Antarctica which basically houses all
these creatures flora fauna plants
animals things like that that were
believed to have been extinct now of
course that goes into the actions of the
beyonders and so on so forth in a great
big huge history that we don't really
need to get into the idea is that it's
largely could be assumed that this t-rex
somehow made its way to the United
States or was brought there but whatever
the reason is where some people will say
it's devil dinosaur which it could
entirely be although there's no real
indication that it is because you know
when you end up seeing this dinosaur is
just a brown dinosaur it's not actually
red but when it when you know this t-rex
shows up it was basically imbued with
the Venom symbiote and so the result was
that it was just running around
attacking everything that it found now
of course this leads directly into old
man Logan breaking free and then he
immediately takes his t-rex out and then
in turn actually feeds spider-girl to
the t-rex which is kind of messed up but
following this because of the fact of
the Venom symbiote is sentient it can
think for itself it functions according
to its own will the Venom symbiote
actually abandons the t-rex and bonds
itself to old man Logan this is kind of
cool because remember what the the
Venom's do
it's designed to do is essentially amp
up the existing powers of a superhero
now it does not reset them to zero and
that's the important thing to keep in
mind when I say reset to zero I mean set
them back at a fresh starting point so
it's not like old man Logan bonds with a
venom symbian and suddenly he's never
struggling with a healing factor again
he's struggling with a healing factor in
so far as his body's normal composition
but the the Venom symbiote complements
that the Venom symbiote says okay I will
provide an additional buffer of a
healing factor for you I'll sustain
physical damage and then basically heal
myself and worst case scenario you get
hurt a little bit but best-case scenario
you never get hurt at all and it's only
me as a Venom symbiote which can easily
recover now the other half of this is
that this story plays on the idea of the
Venom symbiote functioning according to
how it was after it left peter parker
remember when it came to the Venom
symbiote when peter parker first got it
and brought it back to earth we didn't
really know anything about it when the
Venom symbiote was cast out by
spider-man it was angry
it was vengeful and it felt abandoned
the result was that it bonded itself to
Eddie Brock that had a mutual hatred for
spider-man and gave birth to the venom
that we all know and love this basically
ties into that concept that the Venom
symbiote even going all the way into the
old man Logan universe still is just a
vengeful creature it's just angry at the
world just because of the fact that the
Oh Peter Parker cast it out and so what
this does is it feeds directly into the
desire for revenge of old man Logan now
this is designed to kind of tell us this
idea that even if oh man Logan's not
necessarily angry at like his son Banner
jr. or he's not necessarily angry at
like spider-girl or even Warren
Worthington at the end he's just still
filled with guilt and remorse and
oftentimes guilty remorse manifesting
manifests themselves as anger just
lashing out at people and so because of
this this ultimately leads and to him
just almost tearing apart every single
person that he faces off against Warren
Worthington a handful of these guys and
eventually chasing down Bruce Banner jr.
now again in the midst of this argument
in the midst of this discussion old man
Logan kind of breaks away from the Venom
symbiote influenced what the Venom
symbiote just keeps saying kill the boy
kill the boy kill the boy old man Logan
kind of breaks away from this influence
it simply says no and basically just
says the whole reason why I didn't tell
you about why I killed your dad is
because I love you
now also keep in mind the
biggest fear of old man Logan is that
Bruce Banner jr. would become his father
Bruce Banner was kind of driven insane
by a multitude of factors when the
original old man Logan story happened he
was driven insane by the radiation from
the bombs that were dropping when
humanity was launching this last-ditch
efforts to try to stop the various
feelings that were out there he's being
driven by the fact that there was no
real law and order so there was nothing
to sort of curb the Incredible Hulk
mindset and maintain this moral compass
it was just a guy out there effectively
becoming feral and so because of this
the biggest fear of old man Logan is
that his son Banner jr. would fall down
the same path now in truth I doubt
banner jr. would have ended up in the
exact same way as his father just
because of the fact that his father was
a combination of psychological and then
physical issues that all came together
to create this perfectly insane god man
are jr. is just a kid who wants to know
who his dad is so again finding out his
dad was killed by oh man Logan
ultimately results in him neo kind of
lashing out against oh man Logan himself
now of course in the midst of all this
and in the midst of this you know huge
discussion and argument and so on and so
forth this ultimately leads to minimized
Captain America hopping up grab the old
man Logan and whisking him away so again
this all ties into the main venom first
story we don't exactly know what it is
that's going on but the implication for
what we've seen so far is that there is
a story where the various Venom symbiote
soval just run awry where the carnage
symbiote the Venom symbiote they've all
just sort of gone crazy and went out
there and done their own you know
bizarre things and just sort of lost
their lives I have no clue but with that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explain and make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]